police have failed to clear a major
bridge crossing between the u.s and
canada it's been blocked by truckers
protesting vaccine rules police
persuaded some drivers to move their
vehicles but they later reconvened the
weekend has also brought a fresh wave of
protesters into the canadian capital
ottawa where a core group of truckers
continue to occupy the downtown area
taking their
[Music]
outrage to the government's doorstep
it's been over two weeks now that the
freedom convoy has camped in the
canadian capital ottawa
a plan to force unvaccinated truck
drivers crossing between canada and the
us to quarantine spark the initial rally
but the demonstrators insist the
blockade goes way beyond opposing the
rules on inoculations
we're not here about vaccinations and
i can tell you 90 of the truckers here
are likely vaccinated
but we are here for freedom of choice
more canadians need to wake up and
realize that our freedoms are being
stripped away it is not normal for us to
wear masks all day okay i'm sick and
tired of it i'm a teacher students in
their classroom they're sick and tired
of it too
police could not move the protesters off
a border crossing it's one of the major
corridors into the united states the
blockade has affected trade and travel
between the two countries
it's also inspired support rallies over
the border to buffalo in new york state
and as far away as new zealand
[Applause]
in the netherlands truckers rolled
through the hague
and thousands of french police were
deployed to stop the convoy of freedom
from entering paris
[Music]
but some protesters made it they took
aim at vaccine passers and president
emmanuel macron
but also tapped into the discontent over
rising prices
our rights our freedoms are violated
we just have the right to work to spend
and to be taxed
the price of diesel increases wheat
sugar insurance increases everything
increases
police cleared the streets using tear
gas but this has not ended the protests
the freedom convoy's next stop is the
european union's power base in brussels
you